[Music]  it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online  [Music]  demi lovato took to Instagram to share  with fans she's feeling quote better  than I've ever felt it's all about  self-love tell yourself you're beautiful  daily be gentle with yourself eat carbs  without guilt and remember that life is  too short to worry about what others  think  while Madonna shared a makeup free snap  also to the gram Elizabeth Banks who  plays Rita Repulsa in the new Power  Rangers flick took to Twitter to  jokingly throw shade at Cate Blanchett  for her similar getup in thor ragnarok  writing fish stole my look hashtag love  you Kate what up what up Chris Pratt  here Chris Pratt posted this cute shot  with wife on a ferris in Japan for his  guardians of the galaxy press tour he  thanked his ladylove for her support  captioning the pic in part he looks so  beautiful I'm grateful to have you and  the boy with me on this one  [Music]  you